what we have here is the graph of r is
equal to sine of two theta in polar
coordinates and if polar coordinates
look unfamiliar to you or if you need to
brush up on them i encourage you to do a
search for polar coordinates in khan
academy or look at our precalculus
section but i'll give you a little bit
of a primer here let's just let's just
familiarize ourselves why
this graph looks the way it does
when
so what we're doing for any point here
we could obviously specify these points
in terms of x and y coordinates but we
could also specify them in terms of an
angle and a radius so for example this
would be have some x coordinate and some
y coordinate or we could draw a line
from the origin to that point right over
here and specify it with some angle
theta
and sum r which is the distance from the
origin to that point
and just to familiarize ourselves with
this curve let's just
see why it's intuitive
so when theta is 0 r is going to be 0.
sine of 2 times 0 is just 0. so our r
we're just going to be at the origin and
then as theta gets larger our r gets
larger and so we start tracing out this
petal of this flower or clover looking
thing so it starts looking like that and
we could keep going all the way what
happens when theta is equal to pi
over 4
when theta is equal to pi over 4 right
over there well sine of 2 times pi over
4 is sine of pi over 2 r is equal to 1.
so we reach a kind of a maximum r there
and then as theta increases our r once
again starts to get smaller and smaller
and smaller
now we're going to do this in a calculus
context so the first question might be
well how do we express the rate of
change of r with respect to theta pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out what is r prime
of theta
well there's really nothing new here you
just have one variable as a function of
another you just use the chain rule
apply take the derivative with respect
to theta right over here so the
derivative of sine of two theta with
respect to two theta is going to be
cosine
of two theta
and then you take multiply that times
the derivative of 2 theta with respect
to theta which is 2. so we could just
save times 2 here or we could write a 2
out front
all right that was interesting but let's
see if we can express
this curve in terms of x's and y's and
then think about those derivatives
so
one primer a review from precalculus is
that when you want to go between the
polar world and the i guess you could
say rectangular world you have to
remember the transformation that y is
equal to
r sine
of theta and that x
is equal to r
cosine of theta
now just as a really quick primer why
does that make sense
well let's just take one of these
angle r combinations right over here so
let's say
this is theta
and that is our r
well this is our
this the height of that side is going to
be our y
and then the length of this side is
going to be our x
well we know from trigonometry from our
unit circle definition the sohcahtoa
definition of our trig functions sine of
theta is opposite over hypotenuse
sine
of theta is equal to y over our
hypotenuse which is r
and cosine of theta
is equal to the adjacent or x
over r and you just have to multiply
both sides of these equations by r to
get to what we have right over there and
once again if this is going too fast
this is a review of just polar
coordinates from precalculus
but now we can use these to express in
terms purely in terms of theta how do we
do that well we know that r is equal to
sine of two theta so you just have to
replace these r's with sine of two theta
so y
would be equal to
sine of two theta sine
of two theta times sine of theta times
sine of theta
and x
is going to be equal to sine of two
theta
sine
of two theta times cosine of theta
times
cosine of theta just like that but now
we can use these expressions to find the
rate of change of y with respect to
theta find a general expression for it
pause the video and see if you can do
that
all right let's work through it together
well this is once again we're just going
to use our derivative techniques so i
could write y prime of theta the
derivative of y with respect to theta
just going to use the product rule right
over here derivative of this first
expression is 2
cosine of 2 theta cosine of 2 theta
we've already seen that that's just
coming out of the chain rule and then
times the second expression
sine
of theta and then plus
plus the first expression
sine of two theta sine
of two theta
times the derivative of the second
expression derivative of sine of theta
is cosine
of theta fair enough and we do the same
thing for x x prime
of theta
derivative of the first expression it is
going to be
2 times cosine of 2 theta 2 times cosine
of 2 theta times the second expression
cosine
of theta and then you're going to have
the first expression
sine
of 2 theta times the derivative of the
second expression which is negative sine
of theta negative
sine
of theta and we could use this we could
actually evaluate these at points for
example we could say well what's
happening when theta is equal to pi over
4
so when theta is pi over 4 i'll do that
in black right over here
we are going to be at this point
right over there
well let's evaluate it so
if i were to say
y prime
of pi over 4
is equal to let's see
this is going to be equal to
2 cosine of pi over 2 2 times pi over 4
times sine
of pi
over 4
plus
sine of 2 times pi over 4 is sine of
pi
over 2
times cosine of pi over 4
cosine
of pi
over 4. what is this going to be equal
to
well cosine of pi over 2 is 0. so if
that's 0 all of this stuff's going to be
0 and here's sine of pi over 2 this is 1
cosine of pi over 4 is square root of 2
over 2 square root of 2
over 2 so this is going to be equal to
square root of 2 over 2.
and actually just for the sake of saving
some space i'll just write it right over
here it's going to be equal to square
root of 2 over 2. well we could do the
same exercise with x
we could say x prime
of
pi
over 4.
let's see we're still going to have 2
times cosine of 2 times pi over 4 so
that's going to be 2 times cosine of pi
over 2. this first part right over here
is going to look the same so that first
term is going to be 0 then we're going
to have minus so this is all going to be
0.
so then we're going to have minus
sine
of pi
over 2 times pi over 4 is sine of pi
over
sine of pi over 2
and then times
sine of pi over 4 sine
of pi
over 4.
now this is just going to be 1
and so this is going to be equal to and
this is square root of 2 over 2 as well
so this is negative square root of 2
over 2.
let's see why that makes sense so let's
think about what happens as theta
increases here if you increase theta a
little bit from pi over 4 if you
increase it just a little bit
your y your y coordinate continues to
increase so it makes sense you have a
positive slope here but what happens to
your x coordinate as theta increases a
little bit as theta goes from there to
there well then your x coordinate starts
to decrease when theta increases so
that's why it makes sense that you have
a negative rate of change right over
here
now the next question that you might say
is well i want to find the rate of
change of y with respect to x because i
want to figure out the slope of the
tangent line right over there and it
looks like it has a slope of negative 1
but how would we actually calculate it
well one way to think about it is the
derivative of y
the derivative of y with respect to x
is going to be equal to
the derivative of y with respect to
theta
over the derivative of x with respect to
theta
and so at that value so
at
theta is equal to pi over 4 this is
going to be equal to
positive square root of 2 over 2
over negative square root of 2 over 2
negative square root of 2 over 2 and
this all simplifies to being equal to
negative 1 which makes sense this does
look indeed
like a tangent line that has a slope of
negative 1. so hopefully this puts it
all together you're feeling a little bit
more comfortable you got to review a
little bit of the polar coordinates but
we've augmented that knowledge by
starting to take some derivatives